nearly 19 years after calling off their
first one and getting hitched later in
Vegas Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez are
celebrating this weekend and of course
E.T has every single detail
[Music]
of a moment is this for you though it's
a beautiful moment this weekend's full
circle Love Story celebration will be
held here at Ben's 87 acre Georgia State
the 6 000 square foot mansion is a
recreation of a southern Antebellum
Greek Revival Plantation and is located
around 45 miles south of Savannah I live
down south of Savannah I have a place
out there you know I live down this long
dirt road and my calmest and happiest
that's that's where I go
the home holds a special place in their
hearts Ben purchased it in 2003 when he
first started dating Jennifer and how
about this throwback
that same year the couple arrived to the
estate in the same convertible used in
Gili I gotta make a quick detour
[Music]
and unlike benefit's bargain wedding
last month in Vegas
somebody's getting married this party is
sure to be over the top
Vogue will reportedly be on hand to
photograph Jennifer in a custom Ralph
Lauren gown
T is confirmed A-list party planner
Colin Cowie has been hired to oversee
the I do details he reportedly won't
even touch a wedding with a budget less
than one million dollars your celebrity
weddings are very dramatic uh one
because of the privacy issues you know
because of Paparazzi and press so that's
an issue oh my God there's Paparazzi
right
back in 2003 this was the couple's
stance when it came to wedding day
Paparazzi
out because it seems like to be so loud
I've never been to it I think they do
the helicopters when you're trying to
hide and if people want to be outside
and they want to take our picture then
okay we're not gonna obsess over them
right
that way
[Music]